[Música]
volvemos con ustedes para un especial
informativo sobre la elección de los
constituyentes de chile que redactarán
la nueva constitución del país en un
cambio histórico no solamente porque se
dejará atrás en la carta magna vigente
desde los tiempos de la dictadura de
augusto pinochet sino porque los nuevos
textos no estarán en manos de políticos
tradicionales y es que los
independientes se quedaron con un amplio
número de los 155 escaños disponibles
cuando ya se cuenta casi el 100 por
ciento de las papeletas vamos a las
imágenes de los independientes lograron
hacerse con 48 puestos las dos grandes
listas de la oposición de izquierdas
sumaron 52 puestos en total con 27 de
aprueba dignidad y 25 de la lista de la
prueba y la coalición gobernante de
centro-derecha vamos que se reunió en
una sola lista del presidente sebastián
piñera fue la gran perdedora del fin de
semana obtuvo solamente una quinta parte
de representación con 38 sillas
disponibles
finalmente 17 puestos se quedaron
reservados para los pueblos originarios
que presentaron 95 candidatos
para tomar decisiones se necesitarán dos
tercios de la asamblea por lo que el
gobierno tendrá problemas para impulsar
o bloquear cambios radicales a menos que
logre hacer alianzas sin embargo mucho
es lo que hay por decir sobre lo que
pasará en el siguiente año con la
constituyente nos acompañará desde viña
del mar y guillermo holzmann quien es
analista y consultor político y como es
costumbre está ya con nosotros también
en nuestra corresponsal para la
discusión desde santiago de chile-
patricia luna y comienzo con usted de
patricia hace unos minutos estábamos
conversando en nuestro informativo sobre
como el chile eligió el cambio cambió el
rumbo la ciudadanía les quito los
partidos tradicionales las riendas de la
constitucionalidad serán entonces
patricia los independentistas quienes
decidan el destino del país habrá cambio
pues sin duda habrá cambio o sea esto es
absolutamente histórico en una lección
que fue histórica en muchos sentidos y
los resultados no dejan de ser
sorprendentes sobre todo cuando ha
habido muchas preocupaciones y mucha
inquietud el tema de la participación
que fue menor a la esperada
al final sufragaron más de 6 millones de
chilenos lo que es un 41% de los casi 15
millones que estaban llamados a las
urnas y es 10 puntos más bajo que los 50
el 51 por ciento que había sufragado
para el plebiscito del pasado 25 de
octubre sin embargo la composición de la
convención constituyente va contra todos
los pronósticos y contra todos los
vaticinios de los distintos analistas
que siempre habían estimado que el hecho
de que la derecha apareciera unida en la
coalición de gobierno apareció unida
incluso con la extrema derecha que
ejemplifica el partido de josé antonio
kast en una sola lista y en un sistema
electoral que utiliza el método de un
que favorece las listas y los partidos
era muy difícil que los independientes
obtuviera representación que han
obtenido así que es una sorpresa en
muchos sentidos la composición de esta
convención constituyente donde la
centroizquierda y la izquierda más
extrema está presente y lo que obligará
a tener que realizar acuerdos porque
ninguna de las fuerzas tiene más de un
tercio por lo tanto es necesario sí o sí
que todos alcancen acuerdos de ses
patricia y la bienvenida también para
guillermo holzmann es desde viña del
madre de nuestro analista y consultor
político con quien vamos a estar
conversando sobre los devenires de estas
decisiones
guillermo buen día para usted y la
ciudadanía le dio la espalda a la
derecha tradicional de chile el
presidente sebastián piñera dijo que su
gobierno y que otros partidos políticos
tradicionales deben prestar atención al
mensaje alto y claro de que no han
respondido adecuadamente a las
necesidades de los ciudadanos como se
verán afectadas sus posiciones políticas
al momento de redactar los nuevos textos
la verdad es que tal cual se señalaba el
resultado ha sido sorprendente hay un
voto que es anti conservador y también
anti derecha que ha quedado en evidencia
y que va a obligar a distintos actores
no solamente a negociar y conversar sino
aquí a priorizar el tema importante del
país a futuro en esa es de sentido una
convención incluyente con paridad de
género como pueblo originario y con un
tiempo acotado para redactar la valla
hay que hacerse cargo no solamente de
interpretar el pasado sino que también
diseñar y dibujar el futuro y
probablemente es ahí donde el diálogo
puede ser mucho más lucky pero y eso lo
que está representado hoy día en el
resultado las urnas donde finalmente los
partidos tradicionales han terminado con
una muy exigua en representación y los
independientes han abrazado dentro de lo
que son los resultados de la
constituyente pero también en
gobernadores y también lo político ha
pasado con alcaldes y concejales
bueno para las personas que se conectan
con nosotros a esta hora en france 24
vamos a escuchar nuevamente las palabras
pronunciadas por el presidente sebastián
piñera
en estas elecciones
la ciudadanía nos ha enviado un claro y
fuerte mensaje al gobierno y también a
todas las fuerzas políticas
tradicionales
no estamos sintonizando
adecuadamente con las demandas y con los
anhelos de la ciudadanía
y estamos siendo interpelados por nuevas
expresiones y por nuevos liderazgos es
una gran oportunidad para que los
chilenos nos reencontremos para que
podamos sanar el alma de nuestra nación
y para que podamos construir juntos los
caminos que recorreremos en el futuro
nosotros y las generaciones que vendrán
un sebastián piñera que una vez más se
tiene que reconocer que estaba
equivocado y recordemos que al inicio de
los levantamientos del 2019 él comenzó
condenando las protestas y las
manifestaciones después se tuvo que
conceder no solamente la violencia
policial sino la legitimidad de los
pedidos ciudadanos y guillermo otro tema
que fue protagonista de este fin de
semana fue el abstencionismo
votaron aproximadamente 3.5 millones de
personas según las últimas encuestas
hasta la noche y mucho menos que los más
de 7 millones de que aprobaron la
constituyente en plebiscito a qué se
debe este fenómeno
en el que creo que van a ver varias
aplicaciones para ello en primer lugar
creo que las tensiones partes de una
actitud un comportamiento de castigo
hacia el sistema político en general la
bienvenida aplicación que uno hace es
que la gente no cree en el sistema no
confíe en el sistema y dentro del
sistema están los partidos políticos
está la estructura normal de poder en lo
económico en lo social estamos en lo que
es la instalación donde las autoridades
dentro de altura al estado y ahí yo creo
que tenemos un gran problema porque esta
abstención no debió haber sucedido
cuando digo no debió es porque todo
hacía prever de que la gente tenía mucho
interés en la participación la
convención cliente qué pasó en la última
semana que hizo cambiar todo eso no ya
no se va no solamente a la pandemia hay
elementos mucho más profundos que es
necesario analizar digamos colocarla en
la mesa para empezar a conversar
probablemente la convención
constitucional cuando empieza a trabajar
en todo ello se va a empezar a
cuestionar también este tiempo de cosas
porque la convención debe tener
legitimidad y claramente menos del 50
esa legitimidad de origen que debe tener
toda carta magna y ahí yo creo que hay
un ningún tema que llamamos de que
resolver digamos en el acuerdo político
pero que sea en sintonía con el ambiente
social que hay o de lo contrario vamos a
tener una convención formal cambios
serios reunida en el lugar establecido
para ello y una convención informal que
va a caer en la calle y probablemente
eso es lo que se va a tener que evitar y
trabajar para que no suceda
bueno pues es que hay muchísima
expectativa puesta en los independientes
porque se les entregó el destino el
futuro constitucional del país y la
ciudadanía pues va a tener que estar
exigiendo resultados entonces qué opina
usted de que cambie de manos pase de
políticos a civiles activistas hasta
actores había escritores entre entre los
candidatos que se presentaron que pase a
manos de ellos la redacción del futuro
del país
yo creo que va a ser un desafío enorme
para todos nosotros porque en general en
américa latina' estábamos acostumbrado a
que este tipo de cosas la hagan los que
saben la hagan lo que han estudiado para
ellos pero acá lo que se está diciendo
es que la sociedad tiene otras y otras
muchas demandas tiene otras necesidades
de kirchner para el príncipe su propio
futuro y acá hay una evolución social
que no solamente le corresponde a
aquiles sino que a gran parte de los
países occidente y donde entiende se
está estamos enfrentando un desafío que
no pensábamos que íbamos a tener que
enfrentarlo y tenemos que superarlo y es
ahí donde la convicción y los valores
están reemplazando a las ideologías la
convicción de los valores está
reemplazando a lo que a un modelo de
sociedad y esta convicción de valores
finalmente se ha canalizado a través de
lo independiente
bueno guillermo y otro tema que quisiera
tocar con usted antes de pasar a
conversar un rato con patricia es que
uno uno uno de los grandes movimientos
que hizo parte de los levantamientos
sociales desde 2019 fue el movimiento
feminista por primera vez en la historia
esta elección no tuvo paridad de género
con el fin de escribir un texto que
tenga también una perspectiva feminista
las mujeres tienen que tener un mínimo
de 45 por ciento de representación
quisiera preguntarle cómo fue este
proceso para alcanzar la paridad en las
listas y qué importancia va a tener la
voz de las mujeres dentro de la
redacción de los textos desde su
perspectiva
a ver yo mucha importancia porque solo
hecho que se imponga la variedad de
género tanto para pueblo originario como
para y los representantes de todos los
movimientos partidos e incluso
independientes vas a hacer un uso un
salto cuántico las gracias tienen que
antes nunca se había hecho y me parece
que es un tema también que a nivel
internacional ha llamado mucho la
atención el 50 por ciento de la
convención constituyente es decir 69
mujeres van a estar presentes ahí
cooperando redactar la constitución y
eso es un elemento de incorporación que
se debe tanto a los movimientos
feministas como a la propia evolución de
la sociedad en términos de aceptación de
la iv de la mujer en las actividades
tanto empresariales como estatales y
políticas y es hoy día está claramente
establecido y eso va a ser un aporte sin
lugar a duda y ese aporte que
probablemente va a permitir no solamente
colocar temas que de otra forma no
estarían presentes sino que también
llegará a acuerdos y acuerdos que sean
muchos más sustantivos en términos de
que son representativos de todo el
cuerpo social donde no solamente hay
hombre o mujeres sino que hay una de
personas con distintas creencias o
distintas tendencias deben estar también
representadas allí yo creo que el
sentido común femenino y el sentido
común que está exigiendo hoy día la
sociedad chilena va a estar bien
representado tanto por las mujeres y
también muy bien representados por los
hombres quienes van a tener que
definitivamente dejar y se quiere ver de
esa perspectiva no en el alineamiento
tradicionales patriarcales para poder
sentarse en una mesa de igual a igual a
discutir el futuro posible
pues si yo simplemente le agregaría que
es una lástima que en el 2021 sea
necesario imponer una cuota de género
para que haya una discusión igualitaria
en la mesa y para que la ciudadanía esté
completamente representada patricia luna
regreso con usted quisiera hablar por un
momento de las elecciones que también
fueron alcaldes a gobernadores y a
concejales fue un fin de semana muy
movido en chile- todo se celebró la
votación y al mismo tiempo este fin de
semana y a partir de los resultados
porque no le fue bien a la coalición del
gobierno en general en ninguno de los
puestos a los que participó son un mal
augurio para la coalición gobernante
justo antes de las elecciones generales
y presidenciales de noviembre
bueno así es veremos qué pasa esta
semana es una semana bastante crítica
puesto que se eligen a las personas que
van a participar en las primarias como
presidenciables estamos en un año
completamente electoral en chile el que
va a haber cuatro elecciones más en los
próximos meses y desde luego esto marca
tendencia como marca tendencia el hecho
de que el propio presidente sebastián
piñera haya reconocido públicamente la
derrota que impone estos resultados
electorales especialmente en cuanto a
los constituyentes y que dijera el mismo
que esto les marca o les impone una
reflexión en reflexión profunda porque
la ciudadanía se está desconectando de
los partidos políticos fueron unas
elecciones
históricas en la que participaron más de
16.000 candidatos para elegir 2.700
cargos y también en la composición de
alcaldes vemos la entrada del partido
comunista por ejemplo en la
municipalidad de santiago y también del
frente amplio que las elecciones pasadas
no había estado constituido de una forma
tan significativa y ahora apareció con
más listas y tiene algunas de las
alcaldías importantes de santiago en
algunos casos con un porcentaje de los
votos bastante significativo así que
vemos un mapa en el que la izquierda se
impone más en cuanto también a alcaldías
y concejales y muchas personas salieron
ayer a celebrar en los barrios donde se
produjeron estos sorprendentes
nuevos cargos electos bueno y más
específicamente patricia como cree usted
que pueden afectar los resultados a la
carrera presidencial porque estamos en
vísperas de la definición de
candidaturas para las primarias y pues
algo tiene que cambiar la estrategia
tiene que movilizarse
bueno veremos lo que pasa pero
evidentemente si eso es un gran revés
para la derecha y para las fuerzas de
centroderecha que se presentaban unidas
en esta lista y que todos los analistas
todos los vaticinios hablaban de que van
a obtener al menos un 30 por ciento de
los votos obtuvieron un 2020 5 un
porcentaje muy bajo evidentemente la
ciudadanía le está diciendo al
presidente y a la coalición gobernante
que no está de acuerdo con las medidas
que están tomando recordemos que el
presidente sebastián piñera ha tenido
algunas de las de las cuotas de
aprobación más bajas de la historia de
la democracia en chile ha detenido según
las estadísticas a una aprobación de
entre el 6 y el 7 por ciento algo que no
se había visto nunca en la historia del
país y también en las últimas semanas he
estado marcada por la derrota política
que supuso en la prueba del tercer
retiro de los fondos de pensiones al que
el gobierno se opuso por el que presentó
su propio proyecto que tuvo que retirar
al día siguiente cuando el tribunal
constitucional decidió no admitir
la solicitud de inconstitucionalidad han
sido muchos reveses políticos en las
últimas semanas y evidentemente esto va
a tener un impacto en el futuro en esa
transición de los gobiernos de derecha a
la que aspiraba el presidente sebastián
piñera cuando fue elegido
hace tres años
y guillermo en las elecciones
municipales la oposición le arrebató
varias como unas emblemáticas al partido
o vamos por chile con sorpresivos
resultados que escenarios e imagina que
habrá ahora que la oposición se impone
en todos los frentes
más bien escenario complicado lo
inmediato para el gobierno de sebastián
piñera que le quedan más o menos ocho
meses de gobierno en términos de quiénes
son los que implementan todas las
medidas sanitarias a nivel social son
los municipios en consecuencia se van a
encontrar con que lo último medio de
gobierno va a quedar muy dependiente de
municipios que no están en su coalición
pero eso va a estar asociado también a
la manera en que la sociedad va a pedir
más ayuda del estado más participación
mucho más cercanía de parte de los
municipios en torno a las situaciones
que yo están viviendo en consecuencia y
el hecho de que los municipios estén en
manos de hoy día de la oposición y no
del oficialismo que impone también un
escenario muy distinto para las
presidenciales que son las 21 de
noviembre y también ahí se eligen
diputados y la mitad del senado aparte
los consejeros regionales y esos
elementos van a determinar bastante un
giro a la izquierda en inglés que no se
puede desconocer y del cual habrá que
hacerse cargo en términos de lo que
implica para el gobierno para los
partidos políticos que también han sido
muy golpeados por los independientes y
lo que significa en términos de lo que
es la consolidación luego el
fortalecimiento mejor dicho de la
democracia del futuro
bueno
finalmente quisiera preguntarle también
qué tan influyentes fueron los comicios
para los gobernadores dado que son los
primeros en realizarse en la historia de
chile
y la elección de gobernador hay varios
que una segunda vuelta y ahí el
oficialismo tuvo una derrota contundente
y la región metropolitana donde había
una cantidad de trabas de renovación
nacional del centro de esta colina no
logra pasar la segunda vuelta y el tema
se está jugando por ejemplo entre lo que
es el frente amplio y lo es la
democristiana y ha sido una derrota y
muy relevante y los gobernadores gran
parte de ellos han quedado o están
disputando lo desde la oposición con
muchas mejores perspectivas esto
significa no solamente viene a colocar
un tono ideológico a una nueva figura
dentro de la gestión territorial una
figura nueva que va creciendo de
oposición va a estar en la práctica
estamos confrontando permanentemente al
ejecutivo que es de derecha y eso
también nos va a significar un ruido
dentro del proceso constituyente dentro
del proceso político y dentro de la
respuesta de la sociedad a todo este
fenómeno los gobernadores están para la
descentralización del país y es ahí
donde también ellos hay mucha
espectativa respecto a lo que puedan
hacer el futuro
gracias guillermo y para hacer un repaso
vamos a ver que a pesar de las
modificaciones y reformas que ha tenido
la constitución a través del tiempo la
constitución actual una gran parte de la
ciudadanía asegura que es ilegítima y
que no los representa además que ha
permitido que el país sea uno de los más
desiguales de la región pese al
desarrollo económico que se conoce de
chile- y que se ve desde el exterior
vamos a ver cuáles son las principales
críticas a la constitución actual
la actual constitución chilena que se
cambiara establece que el agua es
privada lo que no ocurre en ningún otro
país del mundo los chilenos pagan una de
las tarifas más altas de américa latina'
para consumir agua potable que en su
gran mayoría es propiedad de empresas
transnacionales
lo mismo ocurre con los recursos
minerales la constitución permite que
compañías privadas extranjeras extraigan
los bienes naturales que son un pilar de
la economía del país como el litio y el
cobre pero sin contemplar la
participación de industrias nacionales
ni del estado
la actual constitución también habla del
estado subsidiario lo que significa que
el estado vigila a los particulares que
prestan los servicios de salud educación
o seguridad social pero no provee
directamente las prestaciones para que
los ciudadanos accedan a ellos los
servicios públicos de salud educación y
pensiones son calificados de precarios
en el país
precisamente por eso es que la
constitución era difícil de cambiar en
la carta magna estaba determinado que
cualquier modificación debe contar con
el apoyo de dos tercios de los
legisladores tanto del senado como de la
cámara lo que hace que las
modificaciones sean muy difíciles de
aprobar todo eso fue lo que impulsó el
voto mayoritario para cambiar la
constitución pues gran parte de la
población chilena asegura que es
legítimo tener una carta magna heredada
de la dictadura y por eso cuando la
propuesta de una hoja en blanco para
trazar las nuevas reglas del juego
guillermo regreso con usted esta vez
para preguntarle por la incidencia y el
hecho histórico de que 17 escaños estén
por primera vez en su historia
reservados a los 10 pueblos originarios
que existen en chile esta es una
reivindicación no sólo necesaria sino
que es además justa cuál será el peso de
los escaños indígenas dentro de las
decisiones recordemos que se necesitan
dos tercios de asamblea para que los
textos que se redacten sean aprobados y
ahí seguramente tanto las izquierdas
como en la coalición de derecha pues van
a querer conquistar esos escaños
exactamente antes de el resultado de
estas elecciones de fin de semana se
pensaba que los pueblo originario iban a
ser de alto grandes articuladores para
lograr mayorías hoy día van a ser parte
de la mesa de diálogo en condiciones de
igualdad y antes se tenían una y una
posición en la cual su voto iba a servir
a intereses de otros partidos hoy día
están en condiciones de igualdad yo creo
que eso es una gran noticia para poder
lograr un mejor diálogo y un mejor y
espacio de acuerdo y convergencia entre
todas las ideas que se van a colocar en
la constitución lo segundo es que dentro
de los pueblos originarios los temas más
importantes no solamente tienen que ver
con el reconocimiento sino que cómo se
va a hacer ese reconocimiento que a
través de la multiculturalidad ahora
como se multinacionalidad y es ahí donde
probablemente haya un debate mucho más
intenso en todo lo que es lo que se
refiere pero estando a la misma mesa la
posibilidad de que se avance acuerdos
concretos que fortalezcan lo que es el
chile hoy día y la perspectiva de estilo
futuro va a ser mucho más potente y con
todo lo que significa en términos de la
demanda de los pueblos originarios
el pueblo mapuche hay 10 que están
representados hay 8 más que no tienen
representación que son muy pocos en
términos de la cantidad de personas que
esos son herederos o mantienen el linaje
de los pueblos originarios que estaban
en esquina inicialmente y en esa
perspectiva del bloque europeo
originarios porque tuvieran la muerte
que hoy día visitó van a estar tentados
de igual a igual en la mesa y no van a
hacer un elemento que sirva para poder
sumar alguna mayoría o no dentro de los
dos tercios que se requiere para aprobar
la constitución justicia histórica es lo
que ellos demandan en este momento y
vamos a ver en este instante cuáles son
esos pedidos específicos que tienen los
miembros de los escaños indígenas
elisa loncón lleva toda su vida
defendiendo y enseñando el mapudungun la
lengua del pueblo originario mayoritario
en chile los mapuches que representan el
10 por ciento de la población chilena
de crédito representa ser una política
genocida
mi vida
no nuestra tengo uriz aquí presenta un
recurso ante el ministerio de educación
tras que se publicara un decreto que
convierte el mapudungún en una
asignatura optativa y no obligatoria
como hasta ahora para los niños mapuches
para la lengua indígenas son parte de
los derecho humano fundamental defensora
de su lengua y líder social elisa es una
de los 39 candidatos mapuches que opta a
uno de los 17 escaños reservados a
pueblos originarios de los 155
disponibles para escribir una nueva
constitución en chile
nuestro interés es llegar a la
constitución es
en pos de esa justicia histórica pero al
mismo tiempo de nuestras contribuciones
como naciones originarias
buscan la plurinacionalidad y la nueva
constitución chilena aportando su visión
de la naturaleza para dejar atrás un
modelo neoliberal donde el agua y los
territorios han sido muchas veces
privatizados aunque 17 escaños no les
parecen suficientes por primera vez en
la historia podrán votar por sus propios
representantes yo estoy esperanzada este
es un sueño es un sueño del pueblo
mapuche que yo escuché desde pequeña y
que bueno en el tiempo que llevo de vida
también lo he acariciado y lo he vuelto
a soñar y yo creo que algo alcanzaremos
en esta en este primer intento de tener
los escaños reservados un sueño para un
pueblo que necesita aún justicia llegar
al siglo 21 para por primera vez en
muchos siglos ser reconocidos como parte
de la institucionalidad
y regresamos al gráfico para ver cómo va
a quedar conformada esta constituyente
que dentro de un año tendría que
entregar un texto que tendrá que ser
votado por la ciudadanía para que la
constitución efectivamente se modifique
los independientes lograron hacerse con
48 puestos las dos grandes listas desde
la oposición de izquierdas sumaron 52 en
total con 27 de aprueba dignidad y 25 de
la lista de la prueba aparte de eso la
coalición gobernante de centro-derecha
vamos del presidente sebastián piñera
fue la gran castigada de las jornadas de
este fin de semana con solamente una
quinta parte de la representación es
decir 38 escaños y 17 puestos quedaron
reservados para los pueblos originarios
que como escuchábamos ellos mismos dicen
no les parece suficiente pero es un gran
comienzo para reescribir la carta magna
guillermo holzmann y quiero preguntarle
ahora por lo que viene en estos meses
para la redacción de una nueva
constitución son de nueve meses a doce
meses los que tienen estos
constituyentes para redactar la carta
magna- de un país este tiempo es
suficiente para llegar a acuerdos y para
tener una redacción que en el futuro sea
la guía jurídica y la guía en general de
derechos humanos para el país
esperamos que así sea de 12 meses y al
tiempo suficiente hay muchos quienes
sostienen de que 12 meses seguir muy
poco tiempo pensando básicamente de que
la convención de cliente se va a
encargar ahora en la primera semana de
junio primera quincena de junio y desde
ahí empiezan a contarse los primeros
nueve meses we y de posteriormente la
eventual extensión porque me hacen más
pero barajan que el agua convención
funciones requiere tener en no solamente
un presidente o vicepresidente que va a
ser también por paridad de género
requiere un reglamento de funcionamiento
y requiere la integración de una
secretaría técnica con especialistas y
expertos cuánto tiempo va a demorar y
vamos a aprobar un reglamento en estas
condiciones este probablemente la
pregunta aquí y vamos a tener que
responder
ya la próximas semanas y establecer
tiene cuando efectivamente se empieza a
contar el minuto de una nueva que se
debate una nueva constitución porque eso
va a empezar realmente cuando tengamos
el reglamento en consecuencia hay varios
varios días o semanas quieto va a
demorar lo concreto es que se base el
esfuerzo y así está dispuesta incluso
presupuestariamente para que esto sucede
en un año pero entre medios vamos desde
elecciones presidenciales en noviembre
que van a marcar influir en este proceso
constituyente y probablemente tengamos
que enfrentarnos el próximo año a una
prórroga un poco mayor para la hbo
llegar y lograr los acuerdos en virtud
de cómo ha quedado hemos distribuido 200
escaños dentro de la elección que hemos
tenido el fin de semana
guillermo ya nos quedan solamente dos
minutos para conversar y por eso
quisiera cerrar yendo más hacia delante
cómo será el proceso de la nueva
constitución qué pasa si la gente no la
refrenda cómo será ese proceso para
tener finalmente una nueva carta magna
es decir si la población no reprenda en
el propósito de salir a la nueva
constitución que es con voto obligatorio
sigue sigue vigente la que tenemos hoy
día es decir la edad
tantas veces modificadas de pinochet así
la la prueba tendrá que haber todo un
proceso de implementación de la nueva
norma de la constitución con toda la
implicancia que eso tiene en lo social
político económico territorial
particularmente y eso estaría pasando
desde el segundo segmento 2022 en
adelante donde se esperaría que tengamos
ese plebiscito todo acá se trata de
poder mirar como construimos un país
con menor desigualdad y con una una
propuesta de hoja de ruta para disminuir
a disminuir la definitivamente en el
futuro pero también significa un rol del
estado significa una una ecuación que
debe también tener al mercado pero lo
que no quedó claro que cualquier
ecuación entre estado y mercado no se
puede hacer sin la sierra semana
pues nos queda claro el tema y ahora
debemos esperar a que comience el
trabajo ya que sea efectivo en este
momento de acuerdo cómo quedó conformada
de la constituyente pues hay que ver qué
tanto se va a trabajar con esta
pluralidad con los pedidos ciudadanos de
respeto a los derechos humanos con el
feminismo con medio ambiente con no
discriminación y bueno se cumplirá el
expectativas de los manifestantes que
iniciaron el levantamiento social en
2019 esa es la esperanza del pueblo
chileno con estos cambios y con esta
este claro rechazo a los partidos
tradicionales del país así llegamos al
final de este análisis y de este
especial informativo usted continúe con
nosotros en france 24 y recuerde la
ampliaciones de esta y otras noticias
así como su seguimiento en france24
punto com buen día
[Música]